i like challenges i mean many people
that i know like challenges and
and when i
when i don't have the solution to them i
just don't rest until i find a solution
something that is
i don't know i was always like that and
um
it's just uh
i never stop thinking of it never it's
just uh
and then i mean it's it's very
satisfying and also very exciting to to
try and solve a riddle
and
eventually solve it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm with avishai branski
phd and ceo and co-founder of pixel
medical and he's an expert in
microfluidics with extensive industrial
experience in applied physics software
and systems engineering he is one of the
inventors of the viscoelastic focusing
technique cell analysis methods and the
microfluidic based cartilage
dr branske holds a ba in physics a bsc
in materials engineering and a phd in
biomedical engineering all from the
technion israel institute of technology
get ready for an amazing episode thank
you avishai
dr abhishai branski thank you so much
for joining me i know how busy you are
and so i'm incredibly honored to have
you here thank you
thank you it's my pleasure uh you know
dr avishai um the work that you're doing
is is you know
we're a lot of times we're talking about
impact on the world and and people that
are making the world a better place and
often it's a cliche but you're literally
working on technology that in the grand
scheme of things is going to make a
tremendous impact on on billions of
lives you know the way that you're
looking at at blood diagnosis and both
in terms of efficiency with speed but
also with quality of care
i think obviously the implications are
enormous with the phd in biomedical
engineering from the technion
also as a software engineer and a few of
the common companies that we know about
and the founder and ceo of both
hemoscreen and pixel medical solutions
and technologies a lot to uncover here
dr abhishai tell me a little bit about
you know your university years and sort
of what what guided you both
academically and into the
entrepreneurial world
well i always liked
physics so i
studied physics and material engineering
in the technion i had two
bachelor degrees and then i went to work
at elsin was which is one of the first
heighted companies in israel
an mri division
but then i am very much was attracted to
software engineering so i went back to
the tech union and studied the
computer science
um
and uh
worked at qualcomm which is an
international company as you know
um but then again i felt that i wanted
to have a
a better um understanding more
multi-disciplinary
um education so i got back to the tech
tune and did my phd in biomedical
engineering
and
also did my postdoc there i
mostly
researched microfluidics and
microelectronics
and there actually is where we
discovered this unique phenomena which
the company pixel medical
technology is based upon
and so share with me a little bit about
that
so we're investigating the deformability
of red blood cells you know red blood
cells are very
highly deformable because they need to
pass through
very narrow constrictions in our
sinuses or small blood vessels
and
just
accidentally we tried a certain
fluid which has very unique properties
and flowed the blood cells
in this fluid
and all of a sudden we didn't see any
cells at all
we didn't understand what happened we
thought something went wrong and we
repeated the experiment again and again
we didn't see any cells
eventually we
recognized the fact that all the cells
were perfectly in focus in a single
plane
and our microscope was focused
in another position so we didn't see the
cells
this
later on
was termed viscoelastic focusing which
is a new physical phenomena which
occurs in microfluidics
and causes particles or cells to
perfectly align into a single layer
plane
now
um this is was this was remarkable but
it took me
probably several months to understand
that this could
be very helpful in many applications
where cells are analyzed and counted
up to this date
most
analyzers that count cells
maybe we'll talk about it later which
are specifically hematology analyzers
but
there are many different types of such
instruments they need all the cells to
be perfectly focused in order to be able
to
measure them and analyze them so it's an
inherent requirement for all cell
counters
but this unique phenomena which is again
called viscoelastic
focusing
um is superior to all
um preceding
methods which are also used today
it makes it very robust and it provides
a much
more
pronounced focus
and eventually uh yields better um
results and a better measurement
walk me through the
you know from the discovery
to understanding how this can make
an applica implicative use in the real
world and i i'm fascinated by that
concept and you're making a a very
important discovery but then there's a
bread you know there's a vast world out
there of different applications and how
do you know
what to do with this innovation that
you've just created
well i guess um
when you read a lot of papers and you're
into this subject
into this world and you somehow connect
the dots and you understand that
um for many decades
many researchers and developers have
tried to
reach a better focusing technique and
then you understand that it's very
important
um
the the the
the main advantage of of our technology
or this specific
technique is
that it enables
um
development and manufacturing are very
simple and inexpensive
disposables
so bottom line it makes the the tests uh
much more accessible because if you use
the traditional techniques you'll end up
with a very large and complex
instruments that resides only in labs
whereas using viscoelastic focusing you
can
use very simple inexpensive plastic
disposables and attain the same
level and even better the level of
focusing
right
however it's this i mean as usually i
mean as as it's
usually the case is that you you
discover a specific phenomena but later
on you need to innovate
a lot around this
let's say basic
science
phenomena because
there's a lot of technology that needs
to surround it in order to really reach
a product so it took us a decade
over a decade of r d
um
just to to reach the product that we we
now are commercializing
um which has
over 30 issued patents
which have
they have nothing to do with
viscoelastic focusing but they have a
lot of innovation in them so right
before we talk about you know what what
pixel is today and the technology that
you're commercializing today
take me up again 30 000 feet in the air
and what's happening in today's world in
terms of you know blood diagnosis and
you're talking about the impact that
this can have in the accessibility
um you know what what is happening
around the world surrounding this issue
why is this even an issue that that we
should care about deeply
that's a good question i mean um
specifically now
i wouldn't say after the covet but we're
still in the covid
um
diagnostics uh has has brought back the
spotlight i mean the spotlight has has
been
drawn back to diagnostics
whereas diagnostics was pretty much
neglected before
um the fact that the
patients cannot go to the hospitals they
refrain from going to the hospitals they
need to be tested near
where they live or even at home
um you know pop-up units where
testing is being done all this has now
made a tremendous
growth and an interest
into
quick simple accessible diagnostics
um i think it
goes without saying that people want to
monitor their own health more than
previously um and why not the technology
is there so why not make
all these important tests which actually
monitor your
overall health and more accessible and
and closer to to to you to the patient
right
now if you're looking at today's world
and depicts a decade after you know
working on this technology and
innovation you're mentioning that you
have to create a breadth of technology
to
make this an application right
the innovation that you had a back then
what is that like well i'm i'm curious
about this 10 year journey where you and
a team are understanding that you have
something meaningful in your hand and
now you're working on a variety of
different technologies around it to
commercialize it into something that can
actually be of use a great use in the
world
yeah it's a very long journey
many ups and downs many challenges but
very satisfying um it is something that
i think very few people start from a a
raw crude idea or discovery and
eventually reach a a functioning and a
and a selling product
um it's funny when you look backward you
see that we're totally
not in the right direction we did so
many mistakes and we uh
um
we tried so many different ideas
uh
we have a long
list of
prototypes that didn't work um
and i also it's also funny to think that
when you start you think that you
you know what you're doing and you think
that in a you have a solution but then
you find yourself working
on and on but eventually it converges
um
and you solve
dozens and dozens of problems sometimes
you you you feel that they won't they
are not solvable
um
but we i mean at pixel um we have
developed a totally new technology i
mean all our concepts are totally new
um
um hematology testing
was initially you know dive started
developed at
at
1960s
and um it still is based on the same
principles today whereas
our product is based on a total
different principle it is based on
machine vision and ai
whereas standard hematology analyzes use
laser scattering
and an electric impedance
um we use a disposable cartridge which
acts like a small lab whereas all the
current instruments use bulky
instruments with large containers that
are filled with reagents
everything is very different
and yet we
we provide the same
results as a full-blown blown lab
instrument
and in most cases more accurately
wow that's a
that really is incredible but from a
leadership perspective
you know you're mentioning that there
were times that
people that you were that they were you
had to solve so many problems but
sometimes you reached poems where you
weren't sure that they're solvable
yet as a leader of this you know group
and organization how do you react to
those moments well what type of
leadership
do you require to power through them and
reach the end of a 10-year journey
definitely
every time you reach an obstacle
you
shouldn't give up you should show
everyone else that you
there's always we will find a way
um sometimes you go back home you're
very frustrated but then at night you
always you need to be obsessed with it i
must say that if you're not obsessed
with it
and if you're obsessed with it you'll
find a way around it
and
and after
so many times that you eventually find a
way around it you know that next time
you'll you'll encounter an obstacle you
you know that you'll overcome it
and where is the
obsession where is the obsession coming
for you is it is it from the discovery
and this and the fact that you now want
to see through this discovery is this
something that you've been carrying with
you since your phd
where is this obsession coming from
i think it's uh
i like challenges i mean many people
that i know like challenges and
and when i when i don't have the
solution to them i just don't rest until
i find a solution something that is
i don't know i was always like that and
um
it's just uh
i never stopped thinking of it never
it's just
and then i mean it's it's very
satisfying and also very exciting to to
try and solve a riddle
and
eventually solve it so
right and and so if you had to choose
you know really the most meaningful part
you know as a motivator for you because
you're mentioning that there's a few
different aspects here there's the
intrinsic motivation of understanding
this is a big problem of accessibility
in the world i want to solve it i also
love solving riddles and problems i also
love you know being intellectually
you know intellectually stimulated
so i i understand the combination of
these but but avishai who you know from
your perspective you've been at this for
10 years that's insane
what made you stay here for 10 years
well every time
you you climb the hill and then you see
another hill sometimes it's a mountain
this is really i'm sure that most
entrepreneurs feel the same and and
so you even don't have time to
rest and enjoy your achievement you see
the the next challenge and you just
head on to the next challenge
and
i mean if we were to stop somewhere in
the middle without having a
product that is in the market
and getting the feedback from the users
and that is
so makes us so much happy
then you we won't stop i mean
until we we we reach the point where we
see our product all over the world
and is used everywhere
that is really
gratifying because it does help people
we just had a recently an installation
in papua new guinea
which is
everybody here was so excited that's the
first time they have like in the jungle
an instrument and that is um
they're able
to test the the the people over there
and also in australia remote locations
that had no access to these uh to this
very important test
so after so many years that's very very
gratifying
and so the the long-term
impact that the company like pixel can
have on the world
how do you think through the impact you
know in accordance to the vision that
you're outlining for the company
so as as you probably know we we perform
the most common blood test which is the
complete blood count so um
they're
almost a billion cbc's tests done in the
us alone each year
yet there's so many places around the
world
that do not have access to
the full cbc um
either they just don't do the test and
um this test sometimes can
detect blood cancers
so it's not just uh you know general
health but also could be very
critical
so this is one aspect um early diagnosis
of of of severe
disorders and also
it
may help
prescribe antibiotics on a more
substantiated basis
versus not having a cbc done at all
um
helping fight the antibiotic microbial
resistance again the cbc is so basic
making it making it so simple and
accessible uh would definitely make a
large impact and i think that i know we
can only imagine the ripple effect of
what your
you know what you're suggesting here and
implying of of having you know access to
these tests because you're just opening
a wealth of of the possibilities for the
world and i just get excited thinking
about what's possible out there
now i'm asking you know as a young
entrepreneur myself you know looking at
deep technology and
aiming to work on me as hopefully as
meaningful things as you've been working
on the last 10 years
you know if you're looking back at
yourself 10 years ago as you're making
these discoveries and you're starting
out
what do you know now ten years later
that you would tell yourself and buy
transitive property to me as young
entrepreneur
well we you know we we started from the
technology which is usually it's uh
not advised to start from the technology
but to start from the business
but on the other hand i learned that
many large corporates you know start
from the business but they
end up um
um
not necessarily with a viable product so
it's not there is no real you know
guidelines to whether to
uh
to start from
bottom up or
vice versa
i think that if you start from a good
technology but you also have good
business partners that could guide you
um towards
something which is commercially viable
then you're on you know a good path
no no dr avishai i really want to thank
you for for your time here
but more than that 20 minutes that
you've dedicated to me the the 10 plus
years that you've dedicated to pixel and
developing technology that at scale can
make a tremendous impact on so many
billions of lives in the world and you
know i think that a lot of times i and a
lot of people around me you know we take
for granted the access that we have to
simple things like a common blood blood
test and
we forget that the majority of the world
is unable to know whether something is
going on even if they really wanted to
for us it's often an inconvenience of
scheduling the appointment but for them
it's just not having access to an
appointment and so i'm personally
inspired by what you do and thank you
for everything and thank you for
inspiring me as young entrepreneur so
and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you very much
take care
[Music]